luego de un toque de queda de 54 horas
los residentes de mico life salen a
recibir agua y alimentos
teniendo en cuenta la situación en la
ciudad cada ciudadano necesita algún
tipo de ayuda actualmente hay unas
150.000 personas en la ciudad y las
150.000 necesitan algún tipo de ayuda
algo psicológico algo humanitario
esta ciudad al sur de ucrania ha sido
objeto de bombardeos casi a diario desde
el inicio de la invasión rusa en febrero
por supuesto que la gente tiene miedo de
que los rusos avancen pero todos se
esperan que no nos alcancen y que las
cosas mejoren pero muchas casas en
nuestro pueblo están destruidas y la
gente a muerte respeta mykolaiv está a
menos de 70 km de gerzón la urbe que
quedó bajo control ruso cinco meses
atrás la región de sap orilla es otro de
los blancos del kremlin este miércoles
cohetes rusos atacaron la zona lo que ha
encendido las alertas del organismo
internacional de energía atómica y ha
llevado al g7 a pedirle a rusia que
despeje el perímetro de la planta
nuclear más grande de europa por la
seguridad de la región exigimos que
rusia de inmediato el control total a su
propietario soberano legítimo ucrania de
la planta de energía nuclear de sabor y
jam así como de todas las instalaciones
nucleares dentro de las fronteras
internacionalmente reconocidas de
ucrania para garantizar sus operaciones
seguras
moscú y kiev se han culpado mutuamente
de los ataques que la central de sap
orilla recibió esta semana se le ha
pedido que se sancione la industria
nuclear de putin mientras que las tropas
rusas aseguran que fueron ellas las que
derribaron los drones ucranianos que se
acercaron a los reactores atómicos de la
central